okay welcome back everybody today we're
going to talk a little bit more about
vector fields and vector calculus and
I've had some comments that I think are
really helpful from you that it would
actually be nice to have some physical
examples of vector fields to really wrap
your head around why we might be taking
volume integrals of them so I'm going to
start off talking a little bit more
about some vector calculus and then
towards the end of the class I'm going
to give you some neat examples in fluid
mechanics okay okay so there's a fact
that I want to tell you this is a very
very important fact and it's used all
throughout higher mathematics so in
advanced engineering classes this is a
concept that's going to come up over and
over and again and it's the concept of a
directional derivative okay so how many
of you have heard of the directional
derivative before okay
yeah so this is a really really
important concept and it's a really
simple intuitive geometric concept that
relates to the gradient okay so the
gradient grad F the gradient of a
function f grad F of a function f can be
used to compute the directional
derivative of F in some vector direction
okay so
I'll write this out in math in a minute
in some vector direction V okay so the
idea here is pretty simple let's say I
have some function f maybe it's a
function of x and y or more generally it
could be a function of lots of variables
whatever so I have some function f it's
a scalar function and I can use the
gradient of F to compute the directional
derivative of F in a certain vector
Direction V okay so if you want to know
the derivative of f in the V Direction
right I want to know what is the
derivative of this function in this V
direction in the XY plane then it's
given by we call it the derivative of F
in the V Direction this is just notation
equals grad F dot V so we take the
gradient of F which there's a vector of
partial derivatives we dot it in the V
direction and then we have to take and
normalize it by the length of V because
V might be long or short
okay this looks maybe more complicated
looks and sounds more complicated than
it is this is super super super simple
for example if the points let's say if V
equals the I Direction okay then this
directional derivative in the I
Direction is just partial F partial X
it's literally the derivative of F in
the X Direction if if V was equal to the
J component kind of the Y Direction then
this D V F would be partial F partial Y
this is not an equal sign sorry :
so my directional derivative kind of
makes physical intuitive sense that if I
plugged in some vector V into this
formula I would get the derivative of my
function in that direction V maybe we'll
just verify it
I mean parsh you know grad F is a vector
of partial F partial X partial X partial
partial F partial Y and so if I dot that
into a vector just in the I Direction
it's just partial F partial X if I dot
it with a vector V that's just in the Y
direction it's just partial F partial Y
and if I dot it in some arbitrary V
Direction then it's going to be this
formula here is the directional
derivative okay super useful concept
super simple but this gradient really is
allowing us to look at the the
directional derivative of some function
okay this idea will become really really
important when you want to start
thinking about so we've been talking
about dynamical systems and differential
equations in flat Euclidean spaces you
know X Y Z or x1 x2 x3 but if you want
to start thinking about differential
Asians on curved surfaces like on the
surface of the earth let's say you're
trying to make an intercontinental
ballistic missile that's you know going
to go from one point to the other maybe
it goes this way maybe it goes this way
then you really are going to be caring
about what is the directional derivative
of my object you know maybe on the
surface of the earth or you know in
these non-euclidean coordinates so this
directional derivative allows us to do
calculus on curved surfaces locally okay
that's not something we're going to talk
about in this class that's kind of an
advanced advanced math concept okay good
so now that we have the directional
derivative I want to go back and talk a
little bit more about the continuity
equation that we derived so last lecture
we derive this equation for mass
continuity in a volume so if I had some
volume in physical space maybe like in
this room there's air currents right I'm
talking and I'm creating lots of wind
and if you carved out some volume then
you could create an integral over that
volume and calculate how much mass is
coming in how much mass is going out and
things like that and so the continuity
equation that we had from last time was
the time derivative of Rho I think
really this is a partial derivative plus
the divergence of Rho V equals zero this
is just a statement of the law of
conservation of mass and notice last
time I messed up and I put the Rho
outside of the divergence but someone
corrected me and this is absolutely the
right way to do it so I want to look at
this expression here a little bit more
this is a little bit funny right we're
taking the divergence of a scalar
function times a vector function right V
is my velocity field Rho is my density
and I'm taking the divergence of this
weird scalar times vector quantity okay
so let's actually expand this term out
and see what it looks like so if I am do
of Rho V well Rho V is essentially this
is div of Rho V 1 times Rho V 2 times
Rho V 3 right my my three velocity
components be in the X Direction y
direction and z direction okay and so if
I take the divergence of this then I'm
taking the partial of the first term
with respect to X plus the partial of
the second term with respect to y plus
the partial of the third term with
respect to Z ok and partial Rho v1 this
is a scalar function now with respect to
X is equal to Rho X v1 plus Rho V 1 X
subscript X means I'm taking the partial
derivative with respect to X ok so this
is just the chain rule a partial
derivative of a times B is partial a B
plus B partial a ok so this is my you
know partial partial X term plus Rho sub
y v2 plus Rho v2 y it's my partial
partial Y term plus Rho partial in the Z
Direction times v3 plus Rho V 3 partial
derivative in the Z direction ok does
this make sense what I did here I just
took my my function Rho times V and I
wrote it as a vector function so each
component is a scalar function and I can
take the partial derivative of each of
these with respect to x y&z and add them
up that's the divergence ok any
questions at this point
ok ok
and so now I'm going to pull apart each
of these terms so all of the terms that
just have a row with no derivatives in
row I'm going to pull those to one side
so I get Rho times V 1 X is you know
partial V 1 partial X plus partial V 2
partial y plus partial V 3 partial Z and
then I'm going to collect all of the
terms that have a partial derivative of
Rho so Rho X Rho a Rho Z terms so plus
you know Rho X V 1 plus Rho y V 2 plus
Rho Z V 3 okay what is this quantity
here inside this first parenthesis
so like inside here partial v1 partial X
plus partial V - partial y plus partial
v3 partial Z what is that divergence of
V right so this is Rho times the
divergence of V and what's this what's
this term here
yeah del Rho dot V yeah exactly plus
grad row dotted in the V Direction okay
right if I took grad row I'd get a
vector of partial Rho partial X partial
Rho plus y or Y partial R over partial Z
and if I dotted it with V then I would
get this sum here so this essentially
you can take the chain rule of
divergences okay there's kind of this
vector identity this is this is just the
chain rule of divergence of a scalar
function times a vector function it's
equal to Rho divergence of V plus grad
Rho dot V and remember this is the
directional derivative that we just
wrote down this term here is the
derivative in the V direction of Rho x
times the length of V but it's
essentially just the derivative and of
my density in the in the V Direction
that's what this term means physically I
have a density function I'm taking the
derivative in the direction of the
vector field okay okay good so we're
getting somewhere now so now we have our
continuity equation and this funny
divergence of Rho V term we actually now
can break it up into simpler terms that
make a little more physical sense and
this is what we end up doing in most
advanced physical systems and elastic
equations in quantum mechanics in fluid
mechanics is we take our constitutive
relationships our partial differential
equations that represent some
conservation law and we start thinking
like what do each of these terms
physically mean is one of these terms a
mass-production term is one of these
terms a you know divergence of my
velocity field term and so we can
actually start writing writing these
things down in a way that actually makes
sense so this is plus Rho times the
divergence of V
plus grad row dotted in the V direction
this always has to equal zero for any
system where mass is conserved
okay so unless you have a gas and you're
actually beaming in a laser so that
you're changing the okay what's a good
example there are actually some fluent
systems where you can have to use
special relativity unless you have any
creation or destruction of mass this is
true okay so this is true for all fluids
that will mostly ever be working with
unless you deal with so it turns out
that the lasers that they use for like
the airborne laser are huge chemical
chemical lasers they essentially have a
big tube and you have something like
hydrogen gas coming in on one side and
maybe fluorine gas is it f4 just FL call
F I'm not a chemist fluorine gas coming
in on the other side and these things
react extremely violently and they start
having resonant shockwaves and they
create tremendous amounts of energy and
then you actually need energy equations
and there is different types of maths
that are being created if you wanted to
look at the fluid dynamics after a
nuclear bomb explosion this wouldn't be
strictly speaking true you'd need an
energy equation and you'd also need
equations for the different chemical
species that are being created but this
is true for all gases and fluids that
were normally going to come in contact
with okay so if if Rho is constant
everywhere
so what are some examples of fluids
where my density is basically constant
everywhere is the air a good example of
a fluid where my density is constant
everywhere at low speeds locally in this
room yes in you know around the wing of
an airplane
no all right because it's compressible
at high speeds a good example is like
liquid water okay so the water in my
coffee cup is basically incompressible
you would be hard-pressed to change Rho
at all okay you have to try really
really hard to change Rho in my coffee
cup you could do it by heating it up but
assuming temperature is constant so if
Rho is constant everywhere then this
partial Rho partial T is equal to zero
that just means my density doesn't
change in time that's fine right density
doesn't change in time and we have that
the gradient of Rho is also zero zero
vector
there's no partial of Rho with respect
to any direction another way to say it
is that the derivative of Rho in the in
V Direction is equal to zero for all
directions V okay this this density
doesn't have any variance in any
direction its uniform and so if my Rho
is constant everywhere then I just
killed two of my terms I've killed this
term and I've killed this term and so
the only equation that I have left is
that Rho divergence of V equals zero
okay and you can say that's the
equivalent to just the divergence of V
is equal to zero so for fluids where my
density is completely constant this has
to be true this is a statement of
conservation of mass for a uniform
density fluid notice that this means
that the diver
my vector field has to be zero and what
did we call flow fields that have zero
of divergence incompressible alright so
we call this incompressible because it
means volumes are neither growing nor
shrinking with this vector field and now
we see that this word incompressible has
a very very physical meaning it is the
condition that a bit of conservation of
mass in an incompressible fluid in a
fluid where my density can't change that
means it's incompressible I can't change
the density okay so there's kind of this
nice mathematical meaning behind this
divergence equal to zero if I have a
fluid where the density can't change
then my velocity field has to be
divergence free or else I would not have
conservation of mass that's the only way
I can have conservation of mass ok any
questions about kind of what we've what
we've done in this this example
okay so this is an example of
engineering approximation so more and
more in the rest of this class and then
in 565 I'm going to be teaching you more
about how do we make good engineering
approximations to simplify our system so
this equation is much much simpler than
this equation okay so if I can get away
with assuming that my density is
basically constant I'm going to and I'm
going to use this equation because it's
much simpler okay this would be easier
to program on a computer it would be
easier to do analytic analysis you know
on this equation then on this equation
when density is varying so for example
if I have a low speed airplane where the
Mach number is really really small maybe
less than 0.1 so I'm going less than 0.1
times the speed of sound then I'm going
to make the assumption that my flow is
incompressible even though it's not
exactly true
okay because I benefit from having this
approximation I got a simplification
okay good any questions about like how
we've used partial derivatives or vector
derivatives or divergence okay this
general concept of deriving a
differential equation a partial
differential equation from a volume
integral is ubiquitous it's it's how we
derive partial differential equations in
almost all physical systems and then
analyzing the vector terms is how we get
physical interpretation about the system
okay so you could write down a similar
equation for turbulent fluctuations and
each of the terms has physical meaning
in terms of energy production or
dissipation or you know convection of
large-scale structures and they're
similar meanings for all of the terms in
Schrodinger's equation the elastic beam
equation pretty much any partial
differential equation these come from
physical conservation laws okay okay
good
so I'm almost done with math and then
I'm going to show you some pictures
okay so there's two things I want to
talk about we've introduced this concept
of a vector field V okay and I told you
that you can do things with this vector
field just like we could an ordinary
differential equation so so some
properties of V so V is often the
solution of a partial differential
equation and this will be the entire
topic of the next quarter is essentially
how to find this vector field if you
know some partial differential equation
okay so one example would be the
navier's stokes equations so if I have
the navier-- stokes equations which are
just some big PDE slightly more
complicated than my continuity equation
including my continuity equation then
the solution of that differential
equation is a vector field so vector
fields can be the solutions of
differential equations that's kind of
one fact another fact is that I can take
this vector field and I can use it as a
differential equation I can say that I
have some X dot equals V times X
sorry let's say V of X that makes a
little more sense right this vector
fields is a function of space and these
two it took me a really long time to
really get to the bottom of how these
two properties are related okay but the
best example I'm going to keep drawing
the same picture over and over because
it's the only part of the world I can
draw this is Florida and Texas the idea
is this V is the solution of some
partial differential equation
conservation of mass conservation and
momentum conservation of energy energy
if I write down those three conservation
laws which are you know mass is
conserved force equals mass times
acceleration and energy is conserved
those are my three basic conservation
laws in most systems then I get some
vector field V in space okay V is a
vector field that is a solution of some
navier's stokes equation some
differential equation and it gives me a
direction where the fluid points at
every point in space so that's this
first interpretation of a vector field
now the second interpretation of a
vector field is it tells me how things
would move if I drop them in that fluid
okay if I dropped a life boat in this
fluid this vector field tells me how
that vector how that life boat is going
to move and I could literally take some
initial condition X naught and I could
integrate it through that vector field
and I would get the trajectory of my
buoy or my lifeboat probably this vector
field also changes with respect to time
remember our differential equations
could also change with respect to time
they could have external forcing that
caused them you know this velocity field
changes with a daily cycle due to the
Sun and the wind and so the solution of
this would look like X at time T is
equal to my
initial position X naught plus the
integral from zero to T of my vector
field of X of tau at time tau D tau
sorry the Reds a little hard to see but
this is the basic idea of what we mean
by a vector field a vector field is a
field of vectors that describes some
quantity like this is literally the
fluid velocity vector at every point in
the Gulf of Mexico and I can use that
vector field to do things like integrate
particles into that vector field I can
see where oil would go if I dropped oil
or where a lifebut would go if I dropped
a lifeboat and it's just like what we
learned in the first half of this class
with ordinary differential equations
this is just some nonlinear you can just
call this this is f of X and T it's the
same thing it's the same vector F that
we've been talking about before except
now this F is a solution of a partial
differential equation okay and it's
funny because the partial differential
equation we define this partial
differential equation by writing down
integrals of V that have to be true
right we wrote down an integral for the
density having to be you know the mass
had to be conserved so I could write
down a volume integral for conservation
of mass and I got a condition on V that
has to be true namely that my divergence
has to be zero if Rho is constant that's
one condition on my vector field I can
also write down a volume integral that
my momentum has to be conserved over a
volume and I would get another
constraint equation a partial
differential equation constraint on V
called the navier-stokes equations if I
was heating up my system then I would
have to write down an energy equation
that my energy you know whatever flux of
energy I have into my system you know
plus the energy total in the system has
to be conserved and I would get a third
energy equation so we get these partial
differential equations based on volume
integrals of V and then those
constraints define what the vector field
has to be to satisfy those constraints
of mass momentum and energy conservation
and so this really I think in my mind
motivates why I'm interested in things
like triple integral of V with respect
to some volume and you know how this
might relate to a surface integral and
things like that so this is really
motivating Gauss's theorem because
Gauss's theorem allows me to take these
conservation equations and get partial
differential equations like we saw for
continuity we're going to talk a lot
more about topic 1 next quarter but what
we're going to do for the rest of the
quarter has essentially established the
mathematical framework for how do we
write down these volume integrals how do
we deal with vector-valued functions v
you know how do we write equations in
terms of operators like divergence and
gradient and curl in a sensible way okay
so that's what we're going to talk about
more on Friday and on Monday and
Wednesday and Friday of the week after
Thanksgiving okay good so let's talk
well first of all are there questions
before I go to like a keynote or
PowerPoint presentation there probably
should be and this takes a long time to
actually took me a long time for this to
make sense
so when people talk about like solving
PDEs talking about code steps but what
good write to get a specific solution
you have to do 1 & 2 right what so
usually solving the PDE is just 1
solving so the my vector field is
usually the solution of my partial
differential equation okay like if I
want to know what is the flow field over
a wing I would solve a partial
differential equation and I would get a
vector field but then if I want to know
what would happen if I put smoke in the
air and I wanted to know like where is
the smoke going to go that would be
problem 2 so solving for the vector
field in the Gulf of Mexico that's
solving a partial differential equation
and then if I want to use that solution
to figure out where contaminants are
going to go that would be part two okay
and part one is huge right this has been
actually both of these are huge these
are two of the largest fields of
mathematics right the largest and most
successful fields of mathematics and one
of the third most successful fields is
vector calculus just getting the
language and the scaffolding so that you
can think about these problems in a
reasonable way okay and problem one can
be broken down into two parts one is
writing down the partial differential
equation based on physics and part you
know the other part of this is solving
that partial differential equation so
here we wrote down the partial
differential equation based on physics
but I haven't told you at all how to
solve this right that's actually hard so
writing down the equations is usually
much simpler than actually solving them
like we don't have a closed form
solution to nevier stokes 150 years
later we still don't have a solution and
we probably never will we definitely
will never will have a closed form
solution because it's chaotic okay okay
so I want to show you some examples just
to kind of get this idea a little bit
more concrete
and these are some slides I think some
of these slides I've already shown you
before but we have a lot more context to
understand them now okay so we're going
to be talking about applications of
vector fields this is just a cool fluid
flow field that I like a lot because it
looks eerie okay so examples of fluid
vector fields v arrow is a vector field
right the flow field of the air that an
airplane flies through defines a vector
field right there is a vector direction
for where the wind is pointing at every
point in space in the atmosphere okay so
I have an atmospheric vector field V and
you can get cool patterns like this is
the flow past a mountaintop and you see
you get this Karman vortex shedding from
the mountain which is kind of amazing
other examples if you have wind flowing
past a mountain ridge you'll get this
huge what's called a wind rotor so a big
kind of sideways tornado looking vortex
rolling and up off of this mountain and
these have been known to actually flip
small to medium sized passenger planes
outside of Boulder so this happened a
number of years ago and so this is a
very well-studied vector field is the
vector field of a flow past a mountain
again these are solutions to partial
differential equations but I'm curious
what happens when I put an airplane into
that vector field okay that's more of
the X dot equals V of X the flow field
created by engineering devices like an
airplane this is a vector field feature
that is derived from our engineering
solutions so you can see that this flow
is being pushed downward these vortices
are pushing down and that's a direct
indication that my airplane is getting
lit by conservation of momentum right
conservation of momentum means that if
I'm pushing air down then
the air is pushing me up okay so this
picture you know essentially
encapsulates what we're doing in the
Navy or Stokes equation we're writing
down that that momentum has to be
conserved and this vector field is the
outfall of that conservation law that's
the solution of the PDE is how this air
points in these directions and you can
see that the cloud is being pulled into
these vortex cores so these cloud
particles are being pulled through this
vector field microburst wind shear super
dangerous phenomenon it happens a lot in
the south and South East in the summer
and it downs airplanes you can read
about it super cool
okay so there's other important examples
of fluids right like beer bubbles so if
you have a glass of beer you'll find
that bubbles rise from the bottom to the
top right now if you just computed the
density of the beer to the density of
the bubble you would find that they have
a density ratio of about 500 to 1 okay
which would suggest that the beer bubble
should rise at about 500 gravity
acceleration of about 500 times the
acceleration of gravity but we know
that's not true these bubbles aren't
going you know incredibly fast upward
they're just kind of rising upward and
the reason is because as the bubble
moves through the fluid it creates a
vector field you can see this vector
field of the bubble moving the fluid out
of the way and because it has to move
the beer out of the way that kind of
puts drag on its motion okay so this
beer has a vector field that's induced
by the buoyant motion of these bubbles
and the bubbles moving through the beer
satisfy some differential equation okay
I I think we should all try this
experiments again you know airplanes and
so this idea here that I can take
conservation laws I can take
conservation of mass
an incompressible fluid I can take
conservation of momentum forget this
integral term just the first part of
this is conservation of momentum and I
can write down partial differential
equations for what my velocity field U
has to be to satisfy those conservation
laws that we know are fundamentally true
for all classical mechanical systems and
you get these great you know very rich
complicated flow fields there is a
vector every point in space telling me
where smoke visualizations would go so
this is essentially a smoke
visualization where I've injected some
artificial kind of simulated smoke and
it follows places in the vector field
and this is that example of the Gulf of
Mexico so this is Louisiana here Florida
Houston somewhere around here and you
can see that the velocity field for what
the Gulf of Mexico currents are doing
allows me to follow where oil particles
would go they're getting stretched along
these directions in this vector field ok
ok so let's think about this example I
told you that we can have a vector field
V or you this is the solution to some
differential equation some PDE some
conservation laws and then I can have
some particle in that vector field right
I drop a floatation device in the Gulf
of Mexico that's X V is the velocity
field of the Gulf of Mexico X is a buoy
I drop it in okay and we can essentially
follow that particle for every point tau
between T times 0 and time T and it
experiences a different region of that
velocity field because it's moving in
space so it sees a different velocity
every time it moves in space but I can
follow it around and find out where it
is at some later time I can integrate
this vector field
this is all that we did in the first
half of the class is integrate vector
fields okay that's why I called my
differential equations vector fields
because their vector fields okay and I
can take some initial grid of particles
some I can drop some big rectangle of
test particles in a simulation if I know
what the velocity field is in the Gulf
of Mexico maybe I have satellite
measurements or have a model or
something I know what the velocity field
measurements are then I can drop some
particles and I can integrate them
forward in time and I can see where they
go I can see where they stretch out to
okay this actually is flow past an
airfoil this is not the Gulf of Mexico
but you could do the same thing for the
Gulf of Mexico and the idea is that for
every single red dot I could take that
dot and I could look at what its
neighbors are doing okay so I drop a
point and I could imagine dropping test
points you know in plus and minus X
directions and plus and minus y
directions so this is a buoy and these
are for more test buoys you can think of
it like that and I can see where all of
them go and if the flow is compressible
sorry incompressible the flow has no
divergence then this volume has to equal
this volume even though some directions
are stretching in some directions or
contracting the volume of fluid isn't
changing okay so this is kind of a
statement of divergence free if this
volume stays the same and so what I want
to do is look for regions of really
really high degrees of stretching in my
flow I want to know at some points here
my flow is really stretching particles
apart a lot okay and I want to know that
because that's where oil is going to be
spread the most I want to know where
things disperse the most in my vector
field and so what you can do is you can
drop these grids of particles you can
integrate them forward and backward in
time and you can see where they go and
where they came from
and you can find these regions these red
and green regions where the fluid
particles were if I drop smoke or buoys
in the flow where they separate the most
in time okay so in this flow past an
airfoil some particles just whizzed by
and go really really fast and some
particles get trapped into this wake
region and go really really slow and so
they're separating a lot and the
boundary between those points is lighted
up in red okay this is just one example
of what you can do if you have a vector
field and you start integrating
particles or States through that vector
field okay so to get the velocity field
for the flow past an airfoil I had to
solve a partial differential equation I
haven't told you how to do that yet
we'll do that in the next quarter but to
solve the positions of these white dots
in time we use ordinary differential
equations alright that's just X dot
equals my vector field of X we know how
to do that from the first part of this
class and these red and green curves are
kind of these time varying analogues of
the structures that we drew in phase
portraits earlier so this is a time
varying phase portrait of what's
happening in my flow other examples of
vector fields right every single one of
the large objects in the solar system is
creating a gravitational potential field
which is thus creating a vector field so
near Jupiter things are being pulled
into Jupiter near Jupiter's moons things
are being pulled into Jupiter's moons
and so on and so forth so you get this
vector field some V as a function of X
and time for the entire solar system
okay so solving for that vector field is
a huge pain we can't do it analytically
we have to do it computationally but
once I know that vector field once I
know V as a function of space and time
then I can imagine what would happen if
I'd
to satellite or an asteroid and then I
could follow that asteroid or satellite
around this vector field using ordinary
differential equations like we've done
before okay
we could also generalize this to systems
that are not physical like if you wanted
to think about polio spread through
Africa you could say that there is a
vector field defined by the gradient of
the polio concentration so I have some
scalar function of how much polio is in
Africa this is actually Nigeria and I
could define a vector field that is
given by the gradient of that scalar
field
so there's a big gradient from here to
neighboring cities right like these two
cities are polio hotspots and their
neighboring cities are not polio
hotspots so it might stand a reason that
polio is spreading out from these cities
kind of like heat and you could write
down the gradient of this scalar
function and you would find that the
gradient points away from the hot spots
into the cold spots and so polio is
being driven from these population
centers out that's a vector field you
could derive from this scalar field if
you wanted to model how polio is
spreading in Africa okay okay those are
just a few examples of just this really
really important idea okay so there are
extremely important vector fields that
we want to study those vector fields
come up all over the place in physical
systems in you know if you follow
packets in the internet that defines a
vector field from computer to computer
so vector fields are everywhere they're
often the solution of conservation laws
of physics equations that we know like
conservation of mass and momentum and
energy and oftentimes we can use them to
see how things move in that vector field
okay so vector fields fundamentally mean
that things are moving things are
flowing from one point to another okay
so for the rest of the class we're going
to be talking about what is the language
of how we talk about vector fields and
what is the language that we can use to
write down to translate our physics
intuition of conservation laws into
partial differential equations so that
we can find solutions to these vector
fields okay so I want to give some
motivation because this can get a little
bit dry when we're just doing div and
grad and curl of V but V is super
important and div and grad and curl are
the language of how we operate with
these vector fields okay that's all I
have for today I'll see you all on
Friday
you